I love science I just think it's
incredibly pretentious and has claimed
too much its methods are great its
constipated conservatism is maddening
because what it deals with is the most
interesting thing there is nature nature
is very very interesting complex and
permits all kinds of radical speculation
about what has happened it's just that
science is also a business and also a
priesthood and also a men's club and
also the the plaything of certain
classes so all that has to be overcome
my method I suppose if method is the
word which I would share with you since
this question about the new age came up
is is not to embrace things which are
started simply outraged bourgeois
sensibilities but to to explore edges to
test edges yourself that's the important
yourself you don't learn about Tantra
by reading about Tantra or ebo gain by
reading about eBook game you know you
have to go and do these things and what
you will discover is you know you will
be fleeced a few times in your youth
with this method you know you'll get in
with some flying saucer cult or some
beady-eyed guru and his fanatical
devotees but eventually you'll learn the
neighborhood and you'll become street
smart and you won't be a mark that's the
goal of a real spiritual method is to
not be a mark and then when you get that
together lo and behold you would think
this would lead to cynicism did you say
well I went and I stayed with Baba ji
and he was a jackass and then you know I
join
the Unitarian uniformitarian muna
functionalists and that was just a scam
and so far the Sun you would think it
would lead to cynicism not if you keep
to the edges because eventually you're
going to come to psychedelics and then
lo and behold jackpot the real thing
weirdness beyond all possibility to
comprehend you know you have just won
the Publishers Clearing sweepstakes of
peculiarity yeah I have a friend in
London who's a rare book dealer and when
I'm in London I'm usually able to
contrive a situation where he has to
have some errand out and so then I'm
left alone for hours with the books
inside these multiple concentric circles
of security and I can open up all the
cases and pour through this stuff and
it's astonishing
I mean the just the the the cul-de-sacs
into which the human mind has wandered
you know logistic the Chaldean Oracle's
the Vernor camera the Hollow Earth thing
and then all this literature of
exploration I mean the the stratigraphy
of the human experiences maps and
machines and Diaries and blueprints and
and out of all this if there can be a
pattern then there's a kind of an
epiphany a kind of a sense of order of
aha it does make sense it isn't it isn't
simply a chaos well that's a that's a
Hindu notion of this same thing
essentially this Ratanak
super dimension we're all and everything
is is suspended and in place if you ever
want to have a very bizarre sub
psychedelic experience when you're in
Oxford go to the Pitt rivers Museum
everybody goes to the Ashmolean and of
course you should to see the yellows and
all that but on the kinkier side the
Pitt rivers museum Pitt rivers was a
early ethnographer in England and and
into one of those Victorian cast metal
and glass ceiling buildings he gathered
hundreds of millions of objects
classified by category so you know there
are like fifty thousand needles from all
over the world in drawers ten thousand
pairs of pliers from all over the world
from all times and but and on and on and
you just and they're in drawers which
you can open and the stuff is stacked up
twenty feet high and you realize that
it's a concentration of Manas it's a
Khan crescents there's one section where
there are over 200 drawers labeled
magical amulets and you open these doors
and look magical amulets
southern Iraq magical amulet Syria and
on and on very bizarre that to me is you
know searching for pattern through the
detritus of human history because I
really think that we are caught up in a
relationship with something very very
mysterious
I don't like religious vocabularies but
an epiphany is taking place something
the consciousness is really important
and it it is using the the stuff of
biology to create some kind of new order
in
and technology I'm convinced has
something to do with it that you know
machines are are are more than they
appear to be and the machine as we have
known it is is to modern technology is
to a possible technology what the
chipped Flint is to the technology that
we possess today in the concept of a
machine which is downloading of a
function into matter is a concept of
immense profundity life may be able to
extend its career by orders of magnitude
through this means and life is now seen
to be I think clearly central in the
evolution and the career of the universe
most stars got her out of existence
after five hundred six hundred million
years that's the average lifetime of a
star we happen to be on a planet around
an extraordinarily slow burning and
smooth burning star that has lasted a
long time but life on this planet has
been here for at least two billion years
that's three times the life of the
average star biology is persistent
biology is a major player and biology is
not and tropic you know a star no matter
how smooth burning and self-sustaining
is on a downward energy curve toward
heat death and extinction biology on the
other hand it pumps itself to higher and
higher levels of complexity faster and
faster and it uses the dying stars as
stepping stones from one to another the
way you know for instance in the
Hawaiian Islands
there's 30 million years of evolution
visible but nope no violent out there
has been above water more than 6 million
years the islands keep slipping beneath
the sea and rising at least at the
western edge of the complex and the life
keeps stepping from island to island and
perpetuating itself Hans Moravec has
done calculations of the kinds of
computational simulations that could be
carried out if you had a computer where
every atom was a switch and the computer
was the size of the solar system with a
computer of that size you could
resurrect every DNA sequence that has
ever existed on this planet and he feels
that you would feel a moral obligation
so to do and that the resurrection of
the dead would become a social project
to pursued with government tunnel
[Music]